始まりますので あの そのカムアンドシー見てくださいという来て
来て 見て見てくださいというのは仏教の一つの有名なスローガンなんです
エイヒパッシコっていうのは
いわゆるすごく自由に話しかけています
別にすごいことを言うんだからね
もう信じなさいとか 話を聞きなさいという態度ではなくて
で ちょっと試してみたらどうでしょうか
見てみたらどうでしょうか？と
誰が来てどんなチェックしたっても
こちらは大丈夫だよというかなり強気の態度でもあります
どんな人でもカムアンドシー
見て見てくださいと どうでしょうかと
品物には自信があるということなんです
で はい まあそれからそれはどういうことかと
できるだけ早くさっさと進めていきたいと思います
で いくつかの部分に分けてあります
まず この平等の理念ということ
で なんでカムアンドシー
来て来て下さい 見てくださいというのかというと
平等 だから誰にでもということは平等ということだから
平等ってどういうことかとね
社会的な差別はね 認める環境で仏教が現れたんですよ
一番最初に で お釈迦様が現れた時代
インドっていうのはひどい状態で
今も同じ状態で全然変わらないんです
あの無常はインドにも無常なんですけど
状況は改良しないということだけははっきりしています
ものは変わっても 自分の状況だけは変えませんと
でお釈迦様が生まれた時代でも
インドの社会っていうのはかなりまあまあひどい状態で
で 豊かな人は豊かすぎ
貧乏な人はまあ極端に貧困
土地がある人にとっては
まあもう地方一つぐらい土地が土地を持っている
で 一人で自分でも知らない
もう歩いて歩くことは絶対無理ですからね
まあ一応言えば まあもう 23区の区一つぐらい個人の財産みたいな
もうもっと大きいでしょう
インドだから それぐらい土地を持っている
ない人々には全くもない
だからもう代々通して他人の土地で生活しなくちゃいけない
だから生まれた土地の使用人になるんですね
生まれた土地が誰のものかということで
それからその社会はもうすごい激しい差別制度がありまして
で まあしょうがないという人もいますけど
たくさん土地を持っていても意味がないし
たくさんの人々が奴隷みたいに仕事をしてくれないと金になりませんだからね
だから当時の経済システムを維持するためには
もう社会差別制度があって何が悪いでしょうかっていうね
そういうことがありまして
それだけじゃなくて この宗教に対してもすごく差別制度あったんですよ
特にこの正統派っていうのはブラフマン教で
ヒンドゥ教なんですね
ヒンドゥー教というのは最近の言葉でブラフマン教なんですね
その人々はもう極端に差別主義なんです
宗教という神の教えっていうのは
自分たちだけの特権であって
一般人には知る必要はないんだと
ヴェーダ聖典なんかは読んでもいけないというふうに言っていたんです
それは読んでいけないというのは悪く悪いことではありませんし
なぜならば下らんことしか書いてないんだからね
読んだっていいことではありませんし
ですごく差別制度で神様にお供えするならば
誰にでもできないんですよ
このブラマンの人でないと
インドに行ってみたら
この試しにヒンドゥー寺院になんか行って
プージャと言いますけどね
お供えしたいと言ってみてください
お供え物はいくら豪華なものを揃って持っていったっても
自分で渡して差し上げることをお供えすることはできない
そちらにいるんです 専門家のブラマン人が
彼が神にあげないと で
神は受け取れないんだそうです
そういうふうなことで
この宗教の世界でもすごく差別がありましたしね
まあそういうことで お釈迦様仏教は際立って平等主義を語っているんです
それからこの いろいろ宗教はね
この社会の差別制度っていうのは説明するんですね
宗教的なんて言えば なんでこういう差別はあるんでしょうかという説明をするんですね
解明しようとする そこで一人の人が言う説明ともう一人の人が言う説明が変わっちゃうんです
あ バラモンの人々というのは
それはブラフマという神様が人間を ４つのカーストに作ったんだと
最初からもう しかし バラモン人に反対した宗教の人々は
そうではなくて もうこれは流転しているんだと
世界っていうのはずっと流転していると転がっちゃうんだと
いろんなところに という考え方もありましたし
できるだけ専門用語 哲学用語は避けますけど
まあもう宇宙も生命も転がっていくんです
もう変わって変わって
そこでいろんなところにもう知らないところで落ち
もう落ちてしまっちゃう
転がってしまっちゃう
だからたまたまある人々はもうシュードラカーストにもう転がっていて
ある人々はバラモンカーストに転がっていて
ある人々は王様を通してそちらに生まれてそちらに転がっていて
どうってことない また死んじゃったらまたどこかに転がりますよと
そういう風な教えもする人々はいます
そういう人々はあえてブラフマが作ったっていう概念はまあちょっと避ける
その代わりにこの流転とかなんとか言ったりする
それでジャイナ教なんかはこの業だと
まあ業っていうのは仏教でいう業
カルマではなくて物質なんですね
魂にいろいろ物質は粘着
執着する 物質執着すると
それで体が出来上がる
だから執着した物質によって体が違いますよと
魂は同じだからということで
それでなんで同じ魂なのに犬の物質執着したんでしょうかと
あるいはなんでゾウの物質執着したんですか？とかね
ということになってくると
やっぱりもうもうそれで魂のいろいろもうあるんだと
粘着力はね 様々なものがあるんだというふうに話をするんです
そういうことで だいたい仏典から見ると
62種類の宗教哲学が現れたんです
で それを言えば この神の概念やら魂
何なのか 業って何なのか
定めって何なのかという哲学があって
それから唯物論者もいて
それで時間論を語る宗教哲学者もいたし
道徳は意味がある 意味がないというふうに道徳的な話を喋る人々もいましたし
ものすごいたくさんいたんです
そういうことで 宗教の人々
えらい忙しいんですよ
例えば時間論を語る場合は
皆様方はインド哲学はそれほど詳しくないんだから
言葉だけで何か何かはわからないかもしれませんだけど
時間論といっても並大抵のものじゃないんですよ
時間 まず有限が無限かというね
有限だという人はどうやってそれで成立するのかと
無限だと時間というのは言う人が
それはどうやって正しいと言えるのかと
大変なことなんです あるいは逆に時間は存在するかしないかというね
そういうふうにいろいろ時間にしても
いろんなものはたくさんあります
そこで私が言いたいのは
そんな難しいことじゃなくて
宗教の人々は時間はあるかないかということで大騒ぎして研究するは
もう考えるは論争するは
もう忙しい 魂があるんでしょうか
ないんでしょうかと これでものすごくいろいろ分かれて
互いに考えたりして忙しい忙しい
それで結局どうなったかというと
自分の目的から脱出しちゃったんです
脱線しちゃったんです
宗教って一体何のためにあるものかということは
もうもうわからない 時間があるかないかということは
もう忙しいんだからね
それ考えなくちゃいけないんです
もう魂があるかないか
それが大きいものか小さいものかと
例えばブラフマン教では魂っていうのは親指ぐらいの大きさのものなんです
これ 心臓の中にいる あるんです
で そういうことで それで親指ぐらい心臓の中に入り込んじゃったら困るんじゃないかという人もいる
しかし バラモン人もバカじゃないんだから
心臓の中に親指ぐらいの魂
何かもう入っていると言ったっても
もうこれは切ってみればないということがわかるし
だからそんなもんあんた方に見えるわけじゃないんだぞとかね
アンゴスティマートラプルシャというウパニシャッドにありますけど
この指ぐらいの完全な形で
人間の完全な形で 人の魂が心臓の中に入っているんだと
だから目に見えないんだから
それはどういうものか
また喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで 忙しくて忙しくて
一体宗教って何のためにあるのかということはもうわからなくなっちゃうんです
それで どうなったかというと
人間の不安 苦しみ 悩み
死の恐れなどは仏教はハイライトすることになりました
で 宗教がやるべき仕事をやってないんだから
仏教はしょうがない この人々は仕事を忘れているんだと
だから仏教では この人間の不安
苦しみ 悩み 死の恐れ そういうことをハイライトして語るんです
なぜかというと 人間は宗教に興味を抱くのはだいたいそういうことなんです
不安があるんだからなんです
現代も昔も同じことでね
現代人の例で言えばね
なんか仕事うまくいかないと何か不安が出てきて
では神棚にでもかしわでも2回ぐらいでも打ってみようかとかね
まあなんとか思ったりはする
それで超越した形而上学的な観念を語ることを禁止する
お釈迦様はそれはもう禁止するんです
そんな証拠もない 試す方法もない
魂はあるかないかとかね
もう天国はあるかないかとか
あんなのはもう考えてもいけない
無駄だよ 時間の終わりがないんだからね
禁止するんです それで仏教は何を語るかというと
日々人間が感じている生きる苦しみについて語っているんです
だから それが誰にでもわかりやすいはずなんです
生きる苦しみから脱出する方法を 2 つに分けて説明もする
人間の生きる苦しみだけ喋ったっても
全然役に立ちませんしね
あなた方は苦しんでいるのではないでしょうかとか
はい そうなんですけどと
それで終わっちゃうと話が意味がないんです
ですから お釈迦様は じゃあこの苦しみをどうしましょうか
こういうふうにしたらどうでしょうかということで
解決方法まで言っちゃうんですね
ですから 仏教っていうのはいつでも生きている教えにしているんです
魂はなんぞやという話は全く興味もない
神が世界は創造したかないかとか
どんなどうでもいいゴミ
ゴミ箱に捨てなさいと
そんなこと考えるとあんたの時間がなくなるんだよと
生きる時間だ もっと我々は日々毎日いろんな問題に出会ったり
いろんなトラブルを起こしたり
いろんな苦しみがあったり
いろんな悩みことがあったり
人生うまくいかなかったり
いろんなことももう毎秒毎秒あるでしょうに
それがそれは何なのこと考えてみなさいと
何が解決方法あるのか
それ具体的なことを考えなさいと
というならば どんな人間にも
昔も今もその問題はありますから
仏教は生きている宗教になっていくんです
解決を 2つに分けてますけど
後で私は 3つに分けますが
あの 日常的解決と最終的な解決と
一応大雑把に 2つに分けて
例えば奥さんがすごくうるさくて
毎日自分を怒鳴りつけているんだから大変苦しんでいるんだよと言うと
あんた修行して悟りなさいというよりも
その状況を見たら その人はもしかすると奥さんに対する態度が悪いかもしれません
それでお釈迦様は あんた
自分の奥様をもうちょっと尊敬したらどうでしょうかと
愛語で優しい言葉で 愛語で語ってみたらどうでしょうかと
あるいは その人が訴えていることに耳を傾けたらどうでしょうかと
そういう耳を傾けてみたら
そこでその問題は解決はします
それで人生の苦しみはすべて消えたと言ったら
これ冗談でしょうし だから 2番目の解決方法も必要になります
えーと 次に この生きる上での苦しみ
トラブルはここ変わるものではありません
これは変わらないんですよ
生きる苦しみっていうのは
人は誰でも不安と不満を感じている
したがって 仏教は時代によって古くなることがなく
常に人類に通じる話なのです
なんで仏教はいつでも私たちは時代によって古くならないと
もうすごくもうもう嫌になるほど言い続けるかというと
苦しみについて語っているんだからなんですよ
人間の悩みについて語っているんだからなんです
それがもう 2000年前であろうか
今のもう 21世紀であろうか
関係ない もう苦しみはそのまんま
面白いことに世界は変わっているでしょうに
昔の世界と今の世界っていうのはもう信じられないほど変わっているんです
でも変わらないのはたった一つあります
人間の苦しみ 生きる時のトラブル
これが全然変わらない
例えば昔 この畑やらね
野菜とかなんとか栽培して
農民の方々は生活していたとする
ああ まあ仕事 その人々は穏やかではなかったと思うでしょ
でも昔でしたっても 野菜を栽培しても
野生の動物たちが入り込んで
それ全部食ってしまう可能性もあるし
突然雨が降らない可能性もあるし
突然虫が発生する可能性もあるし
わからないんですよ 雨が降らないでダメになる場合もあるし
雨が降って降ってしまって全部流される可能性もある
だから 昔の人々は畑を作っても
収穫をするまではものすごく不安で生活しているんです
では 収穫を家に持ってきたら大丈夫
大丈夫でしょうかと じゃないんですよ
泥棒がいるんだから 泥棒が入って持っていったらどうしますかね？だから昔の人にもそういう
やっぱり生きる苦しみ
不安というのはもうあったんです
今は世界は随分変わってますけど
楽々でしょうし 泥棒が入らないように警備方法とかいろいろもうグッズもできているでしょうね
会社までいるでしょうに
家を守ってくれる では
今の人に不安がない それはありえないんです
今も同じことで 今農業をやってないんだけど
会社はどうでしょうかと
完全安全という状態はない
たとえ仕事は安全だとしたっても
毎日いろんな仕事を頼まれてやらなくちゃいけないんだから
そのチャレンジも大変難しいんですよ
きついんです 一仕事うまく終わったところで
もう課長があー 君はよく頑張りました
これから休んでもいいよと言うんでしょうかね
一仕事うまくすると 必ずもう
前よりは 1.5倍ぐらい仕事くれるんです
あれも徹夜して苦労してやったのに
もうやれやれという状態なんです
これは変わらないんです
それで 性別 年 政治 経済
生まれ 知識 職業などの差異と関係なく
生きる苦しみは皆に同じなのです
こういうのを理解してほしいんです
生きる苦しみは男女に別々やってことじゃない
どちらでもある 年によって子供には苦しみがない
大人には苦しみがある
そういうことでもありません
そういう何にも影響を与えないんですね
人間の苦しみがあるんです
しかし 人は生き方次第で
この苦しみは減ったり増えたりするのです
人の生き方次第で 苦しみはあるんだけど
我々にはその苦しみを減らすことも増やすこともできます
で 人間何に頑張っているかというと
この苦しみを何とかして減らそう減らそうと頑張っているんです
だから一部減ってはいくんだけど
その代わりに一応ご褒美もつけて
おまけもあって 別な苦しみが生まれてくるんです
でも人間はでも頑張ってはいる
苦しみ減らそうと頑張るとどうしてもこのおまけがつくんですね
これがかなりきついんですよ
現代人に付いてるおまけっていうのは自然破壊
自然汚染でしょうし これはどうにもならないしね
ゴミの問題とか したがって
仏教はどなたにでも試す
なんか間違ってます 試しできるのですと
仏教は誰でも試してみることができます
なぜかというと 私が味わっている苦しみについて語っている
それは減る方法を語っているんだから
自分に苦しみがあるんだからね
試してみたっても悪くはないんです
で  6番目に行きます それで 第1章終わります
平等の理念 そこで覚えてほしいのは
平等と言ったっても この俗世間で言っている平等という言葉は意味が違うんです
私はちょっと難しい意味でこの言葉を使っているんです
この 第1章に分けたところでね
平等ってどういうことかというと
苦しみが平等なんです
悩みが平等なんです 誰にもあるんだから平等と言うのであって
質的に平等というわけじゃないんです
それで一旦 第1章終わりましたから
第2章に進んでみましょう
それは大義説法の理念という
あの一般的によく言うことで
このまあ仏教は誰にわかるのはあれは大義説法だから
まあどうったことないという態度を取る人々はいるんですよ
なんか軽視するんですよ
大義説法は それ人に合わせてなんとか喋ってるだけのことで
だから我々はブッダの話より優れている話を信仰しているんだぞと言って
仏教の中からいろいろ癌が発生するんです
それからこの大義説法っていうのはそういうことでもないんです
どうやって解決法を成り立つかというと
例えば苦 苦ということを苦しみ自覚する人が解決方法を探すんですよ
ああ 大変だ 生きることは苦しいんだ
いろいろトラブルがあるんだと自覚すると
もう解決方法を探すんですよ
自分の子供がもう引きこもりになったんだと
これ困ったと それ問題でしょうね
そうすると ではどうすればいいか
どうすればいいかと それで初めて解決方法を探すんです
それで では苦しみに苦しみをね
自覚しない人ってなんだ
ありがたいんでしょうかね
これがもう違うんですよ
苦しみに自覚しない ああ
私は幸せやと思っている人々はいるんですよ
そんなの気にしませんと
うちの子はまあもう 3年間も引きこもりですけど
気にしませんね 私は平気で胸を張っている人々もいます
あれは幸せですか？と
違うんです あの人々の状態はもう治らないほどひどいんです
気づく余裕で余裕さえもないんです
苦しみのどん底にいるんです
もう怖くてもう見ようとすることもできない人々っていますね
大体子供なんかある年になってくると
いろいろひどいことをする年がありますからね
もう見ようともしないという
もう怖くて だからそれは苦しみ自覚していないんではなくて
あまりにも苦しみがありすぎちゃって
余裕がない そんな暇がない
もう泣き叫ぶことで もう人生終わっているんです
しかし 皆平等に同じレベルで苦しみに気づくのではありません
それから苦しみに気づくと言っても
みんな同じく気づくわけでもないんです
これまた人間の性格なんですよ
いろんな人と話を聞いてみると
これさえなければありがたいと何か言うんです
お母さんたちに聞くと
子供たちがちゃんとうまく育てるんだったら
もう文句を言うことはないんだと
それにしか気づいてないんですね
あるいはもう旦那の収入がもうちょっと 5 万ぐらいでも上げればね
本当に楽なのに だったら何の問題もありませんと平気で言うんです
何か病気にかかっている人があったらね
まあこの病気さえなければ
そういうことだから 人間には複数に苦しみがあるんです
あるんだけど その都度その都度何かにだけ気づいちゃって
そこは大げさにするんです
まあまあ よくニュースなんかで流れる例で
例えば子供が病気になりまして
腎臓移植とかね 心臓移植とか
何か移植とか何かしなくちゃいけないということになると
それでその家族はとにかく
この子供に心臓移植でもできれば
もう何も言うことはない
もうそれ以上何も望まない
ということにするんです
それで必死になってもう財産ある財産あるならば
それを全部売って金にしたりとか
あるいはなんとか公でみんなに報告して
もうなんとかなんとか協力してちょうだい
協力してちょうだいとかね
日本ではできないんだけど
アメリカでもどこでもなんとかこれもう可能性ありますけどとかね
そうやってみんなもうそうすると話を聞いて
いろいろ募金してあげて
まあなんとかしようとはする
しかし その家族にある問題
それだけですかね 子供の心臓が健康的であったら
その家族には全く問題ないんだというならば
健康な子供たちがいる家族はみんなに問題ないはずなんでしょうに
問題いっぱいあるんですよ
たとえ心臓移植したっても
その子供 またそれから成長しなくちゃいけないし
教育受けなくちゃいけないし
で 病気と闘わなくちゃいけないし
体力回復しなくちゃいろいろあるんですけど
やっぱり人間はある一つの苦しみに気づくんです
他はまあ一応もうなかったことにする
何かに遭遇して苦しみに気づくのです
その人にその苦しみは最大に感じるものです
そんなのは説明しなくてもわかりますね
だから 自分が私の悩みはこれだよという人は
それは最大の苦しみ 最大の悩みだと思っているんです
そこで その人には自分の苦しみ以外何も見えません
子供に心臓移植させてあげようと思って募金活動をやっているお母さんにとっては
この中で何一つも見えません
他のことには興味は何もない
あの問題で その苦しみについて語ると耳を傾けます
逆に 例えばお母さんはアメリカではなくて
オーストラリアの方が治療代はすごく手頃ですよと
また もうかなり優秀な医者も揃っているんだよと
言うと あ そうですか それどこですか？と
そこは聞くんです そこで解決方法を聞く
聞いて教えるとやってみようともする
例えば漢方治療と気功方法で
弱い心臓がまだ子供だから若返りますよと
生き返りますよと言っちゃうとやらないと思いますか？やります
なぜかというと そのお母さんにとってはその子供の心臓の問題はもう最大の極端な苦しみなんです
だから解決法を教えたらそれもやろうとする
それで仏教の話に戻ります
具体的で生々しく感じている
悩んでいる苦しみに対して語ることは大乗説法なのです
だから我々生々しく感じている苦しみについて
お釈迦様が適応して語ってくれるんです
そうするとこちらはおおと思うほどに
すごく耳も目も口も開けて聞くんです
よくちょっとでも見ようとはしない
じーっと聞いているんです
なぜならば 私の問題について具体的に語ってくれているのではないかと
解決方法 だから大乗説法っていうのはすごいことで
ちゃんと有効的に語る
だからそこは理解するために
たとえいつでも使ってみてください
心臓がもうすごく弱い子供がいるお母さんが
やっぱりもう心臓移植にはもうだったらもう聞きますけど
日本の社会にはもうもうどういうふうに頑張れば経済状況状況良くなりますか？とか
そんな話を聞いたっても全然聞いてくれない
だから人に適した人が聞いている
人が感じている苦しみ
個人が最大限やと思っている苦しみについて語る
それが大乗説法 だから聞いた人も理解する
方法も実践しようとする
それで解決方法を見つかる
それぐらいですね 大乗説法っていうのは
だからまあ これで理解してください
ただもうもう人騙しとかではないんで
大乗説法っていうのは子供騙しみたいな話とそんな話じゃないんです
必ずしも必要な話をすることなんです
例えば神様やら仏様がいるんだとか
いろいろね 如来様がいるんだそうとかね
そんな話っていうのは
まああまり人間に実感ある話なのかと
そういう話 人間には証拠もないし
ただペラペラ喋って またごちゃごちゃ聞いていたっても
いい話ということになるだけなって
それは大乗説法になりません
生々しさがないんです
生き生きしてないんです
それで宗教の世界で この原始時代から
このエジプト ピラミッドを作った時代から
今 最近なんかテレビで見たんですけど
このインド インディアンの人々の古い遺跡を発見して
これまたエジプト時代
ほぼ同じ時代か もうちょっと古いかっていうぐらいのことで
ペルーですごい好きなんです
で そのまあその文明もなくなってますけど
だからそういう遠い昔からのね
4000年前も 5000年前から人間は宗教やら何やらあったんですよ
しかし 宗教というのはいつでも神に祈るというやり方だから
そこでこの発掘した物の中にあったのは
この何か麻薬系の何か粉みたいなものがあって
それが石灰の粉と混ぜて石灰の粉もこれも入れ物とかで見つけて
やっぱりそういうものを混ぜて石灰の粉を混ぜちゃうとものすごく効くんだそうです
そこでそれを鼻に吸って
あるいは飲んだり わかりませんだけど
いろんな方法でなんかみんな変なエクスタシー状態作って
それで踊ったりいろんなことをしたり
それが宗教でしたからね
今もそういうことをやっている部族たちがいる
それでちょっと文明が変わったんだから
教会のメッサに麻薬を使うということはあまりしませんだけど
それは音楽か踊りか何か使って
その麻薬状態は作る で
鐘鳴らすは 太鼓を叩くは
インドだったらもう派手に太鼓叩くは
鐘鳴らすはものすごい煙
あらゆるもう煙を出したりして
この踊って踊って踊って歌って
もうもうもう倒れるところまで歌ったり踊ったりして
そこで神を感じたと それはキリスト教にしたっても
イスラム教にしたっても
ヒンドゥー教にしたっても
何も変わってもないんです
それは遠い原始時代のやり方で未だに頑張っている
そこで麻薬状態になっちゃって
そういうハイな状態になっちゃって
それって人間の問題解決しますかね
また逆に知識人っていうのはやるもんですかね
あんなのっていう だから仏教っていうのは明確に違う宗教なんです
そういうこのエクスタシー状態を作ったりとか
それはもう禁止 仏教ではもうはっきりと
酒も麻薬も 踊りも禁止ですよ
踊るならばもうちゃんと理解してね
結婚式とかね 豊作があって喜んでとか
そういうふうなことで踊ったっても
それは一応考えるなよと
全部禁止 あの この神様を信じる宗教である
この疑似体験という概念があるんです
で 神を疑似体験する で
このカーリー女神を疑似体験してなんとか宗教を作ったね
現代宗教 新興宗教を作ってインドの方は見ますけどね
で あの韓国でもテレビで見たんですけど
この観音様を疑似体験する観音信仰する道場いろいろありまして
そこでみんないろんなことをして踊ったり
また断食して で もう寝ないでずっと苦労して苦労して
で それから観音様みたいに服装を着て見守って纏って
それからハスの花とかなんか壺を持ってますね
観音様がよく喉が渇くみたい
私と同じ で まあそういうものを手で持って踊るんです
そこでちょっとでも意識が変になっちゃうと
もうやったぞという感じになるんです
これが現代若者たちがもっと便利でエクスタシーというピルがありましてね
日本にもかなり輸入するみたいに
内緒で密輸 密輸 何でしたっけ？輸入するみたいですけどね
法律違反ですけど で 高校生やらに
あの尊い宗教の世界からちょっと離れているんです
で 仏教はそれとは全く違うということだけわかってほしい
仏教はこの神の疑似体験じゃなくて
田んぼの仕事に行くと
奥さんが朝ごはん作ってくれなかったらね
その人 お腹が空いて仕事できんですよ
そちらに行くとお釈迦様が語るんです
君 すごく疲れてるんですけど
仕事にならないんですよ
何でしょうかと 言ったら
実は釈迦様はもう朝ご飯は家内は作ってくれなかったんで
すごく腹が立って 苦しいでしょうねとか
それについて語るんです
では 君に神様を体験させてあげようと
そんな話がないんです
だから仏教というのはすごく具体的
現代的で 仏教というのは学校で必ず教えるべき科目一つなんです
小学生の時からも教えておいた方がしっかりした人間は育ちます
自分の国でも まあ神様の西洋のあれだから
もうもうやらせてくれないんだから
お寺で全てのどんな子供たちにでも
一応小さい時から仏教を教えてあげると
騙されないように それでもう一つ
大乗説法の これをちょっと知識だけの面白くないと思いますけどね
話がありまして このアヌプビーカタというお釈迦様の説法方法があるんですよ
アヌプビーカタっていうのを日本語にすると
この次第説法という言葉なんですが
次第に語り続けて どんどんどんどん難しいところまで言うという
何か教育的なんですね
一番最初にすごい単純なわかりやすいことを喋って
それからもうちょっと難しいこと
それからもうちょっと心が育ったらもうちょっと難しいということで
次第説法するんです あの苦しみに適応するんじゃないんです
それは誰かというと それも大乗説法でいるんですよ
別に個人的などうこう悩みがない人々も
世の中で家族はそれぞれ幸せでいるわ
仕事もあるわ 収入もあるし
元気で体にも何の病気もないし
明るくて そういう人々もいます
そういう人々にこういう次第説法するんです
別に私が病弱で悩んでるんだぞって
そういう人にそういうこと全然ないんだからね
君 そう元気でね どうですか？とかね
どういうふうに君が毎日生きているんでしょうか？とかね
毎日と言ったっても 時々まあ一つちょっと具体的な例をちょっと崩しています
毎日どうと言ったっても
結構忙しいんだよと まあ仕事はいっぱいあるし
使用人たちもいっぱいいるし
その人々の面倒を見ることもあるし
王様の仕事にも行かなくちゃいけないし
その上自分はバラモンの人だからね
まあそのバラモン宗教のしきたりも適当にやっておかなきゃ
またまずいし それもやって
まあそれから家内はいるんだから
これまあちゃんと機嫌を取っておかなきゃ
これ大変危ないんだからね
それを家内の機嫌を取ってあげたりとかね
でまあ それで終わるんじゃないんだよと
友達もいるんだから どうせ自分が有名な人だからね
友達の接待です あれも結構時間かかりますよ
だからなかなか暇がないんだよと
これはサーリプッタ尊者との対話
サーリプッタ尊者が聞いたのは
君どう何か良いことでもしていますかと
そんな暇がありませんと彼が答えるんです
そこでそれに合わせてサーリプッタ尊者よくわかりました
あんたもいいことしないんだから
どうせ死んじゃったら地獄に落ちるでしょ
その時閻魔様に言ってください
奥さんのことで忙しくても良いことできなかったんだと
だから天国に行かせてくださいと
いて馬鹿にするんです
バラモン人は あるいは友達にも
ほとんど 1週間に 2 3回ぐらい接待しなくちゃいけなかったんだから
忙しくて忙しくて善行する暇がなかったんだと
閻魔さんに言いなさいよと
それで閻魔さんがあんたは免除して天国に行かせるでしょうと
だからそこもまあ その人に合わせてちりっと仏教の生き方を生き方を教えるんです
そこ社会的な問題ない人に
それから知識人いますね
別に金が欲しくないんだけど
知識が欲しい この知識人たちにも順番で次第説法をする
そう書いてありましたからね
この苦しみに苦しみは気にしない人
しかし 知識的な興味がある
より良い幸福を目指す人
そういう人々に対して次第説法をする
だからこれも大器説法なんです
で 次に行きます そこで大器説法っていうのは不完全でしょうかと
これ大乗仏教がこの初期仏教に出している一つの批判なんですね
初期仏教は頭が悪くて
お釈迦様が大器説法ばっかり
もうしがみついているんだと
お釈迦様が語らなかった仏教は知らないんだと
それ言われた途端 私は呆れちゃいますけど
語らなかった仏教ってあるわけないでしょ
あなたは男が産んだ子供のことを知らないんだぞというような話だからな
男だから子供を産むわけないでしょうに
とにかく大器説法は完全
というような考え方がありまして
だからそれは単純ですよ
答えは 人間の苦しみというのは普遍的でしょうに
夫婦喧嘩っていうのはもう普遍的でしょうに
100年前の夫婦が喧嘩するとき味わう苦しみも
今の夫婦が喧嘩しているとき味わう苦しみも同じでしょうに
300年前で子供が死んで母親が苦しんで泣いている時の別れの苦しみも
今も子供が誰かに殺されちゃって
学校に行って帰ると子供はもういなかったと 2
日間経ってみたら どこかで殺されているところは普通にあるニュースでしょうね
その時のその被害者の母親の苦しみも違うんですか？同じでしょうに
だから人間の苦しみというのは普遍的なんです
私だけ 私だけに限る苦しみはありません
みんなそう言いたがりますけど
これは私だけの苦しみで
こんな苦しみは誰にもわかりませんよと
言うのは勝手ですけど
だから本人にとっては自分の苦しみを最大限に見えるだけの話で
それは他人に誰にもわからないわけではありません
他人にもわかります その苦しみは
私だけに語られた教えは
実は普遍的な真理なのです
そこでお釈迦様に会ったら
お釈迦様がこの私だけの苦しみを教えてあげるんですよ
で 苦しんでいる人が私だけだと思ってますから
知ってるでしょ？子供が死んじゃって
マスタードの種を探し回ったお母さんが
そのお母さんが自分の子供が死んじゃったら
あれ？なんでうちの私の子は死んじゃったんですか？と
これ 自分だけのことだと思ったんですね
苦しみは これが不公平だ
なんで私だけこんな苦しみを味わわなくちゃいけないんですかと
これはおかしい 薬でも見つけて子供を治さなくちゃいかんとか言って
子供の遺体を運んであっちこっち行くところで
もうやがてお釈迦様に出会ったでしょうに
お釈迦様は何をおっしゃったんですか？見事に
わかりました 治療してあげましょう
私だったら あんたアホじゃないか
これ死んだ人はどうやって生き返れるんでしょうか？とかね
いい加減にしないしないかと
あるいはカウンセリング受けなさいよとかね
病もあのサイキックっていうのは何でしたっけ？お医者さん
あの心理 うん うん ああ
この心理治療法を治療するお医者さんに会いなさいとかいうのは現代人のやり方でしょ
お釈迦様はすごく違う態度を取るんです
娘と呼ぶんだからね 年下の女の子たちをね
いいよ 娘さんも治してあげます
でお母さんがびっくりするんですね
私だけの苦しみを治してくれるんだと
ではちょっとマスタードをほんのちょっと持ってくれと
で マスタードっていうのはインドでそこら中にあるんだから
どんな料理にも使うし
ほとんど薬にも使うし
売るものにもならないし
すぐ持ってきますよと
お母さんすごい元気で
いきなりちょっと待ってよと
これはもう人が死んでない家から持ってくるんだよと
家っていうのは建物ではないんです
死んでない建物から持ってこいではなくてね
人が死んでない家から持ってこなきゃダメですよと
彼女はまあ人が死んでない家を探し回ったでしょうね
それで何がわかったんですか？というと
これ私だけの苦しみじゃありませんと
はぁ なんだこう これが生まれたやつらはみんな死ぬんだと
それであの悩みも苦しみも悲しみも全て消えちゃったでしょうに
消えて彼女はもうもっとさらに瞑想して悟り開く
だから私だけの話は 本当に私だけの話じゃないんです
このキサゴトミという彼女にお釈迦様が教えた教えは
全ての人類に対する真理なんです
でも お釈迦様の教えは
もうこれはもう世界一で天才的で
誰にも真似はできません
だから大乗説法は不完全だというのはあまりにも侮辱です
大乗説法こそ説法なんです
これができるのは本当のところ
お釈迦様だけなんです
私のところにお母さんが死んだ子供を持ってきたのに
私はじゃあマスタード種を持って持ってこいとは言わないでしょうね
そんな猿真似したっても効き目がないでしょうに
誰だったら私も皆様と同じくそうでね
人は死ぬんだから なんとかね
まあ悲しいのはわかるんだけど
やっぱり見とうなきゃあかんぜとかね
いろいろなことを言うんです
あんまり効き目はないんですよ
そんなこと言っても お釈迦様はすぐ何か答え出します
ですから 大乗説法一つ一つは完全な教えなのです
それで大乗説法の話は終了します
そんな難しいポイントというわけでもないんです
大乗説法だから ブッダの話は誰にでもわかります
次のチャプターに行きます
第3章に行きます そういうことで
ブッダにいろいろ人々が出会ったんです
お釈迦様が悟り開いた日から涅槃に入られた日まで
無数の人々に会って説法したんです
ほとんど毎日 それで大乗説法でした
一つもお釈迦様は失敗したことはなかったんです
で リスト書いてるだけの話でね
俗世間から離れて一生を修行に励んだ行者たち
インドにいたんですよ
ものすごい哲学者たちが
欲もないわ もう全く俗世間と関係なく
森の中で人と顔も合わせないで
何年も何年も修行に励んで
瞑想に励んで それなりに精神的なすごい優れた境地にも達していて
だから並大抵の人々じゃないんです
いわゆる仙人という人々が
そういう人々をそれでも心に何か不安が残るんですよ
瞑想してものすごい気安感感じたりするんだけど
なぜかちょっと心に不安があって
そういう人々はさっとお釈迦様だけだったら顔を合わせて話してみるんです
お釈迦様は答える でもそういう答えはなかなか難しい
その人に大乗説法だからね
わからないんです それで面白いことがありまして
この日本というのは逆さま論理の帝国だから
そのとてつもない知識人でない限り
修行に明け暮れてあらゆる
精神的な境地に至っている人でない限りわからない
ブッダの教えは簡単にわかるというんです
スッタニパータというテキストは日本訳されているでしょうね
それで誰でもすぐ じゃあ私も日本訳するぞと頑張って日本訳しようとする
誰も原文で日本訳しないんだからありがたいんですけど
誰かがした訳を見て またちょっと言葉を変えるだけの話であれわからないんですよ
で すごく読まれたのは中村先生の見事な日本語の振る舞いというかね
あの なんとかわかりやすく読めるような日本語に訳されちゃったんだから
このタイトル何でしたっけ？ブッダの言葉
それがね 短編小説のような感じで読んで
ああ わかりました よくよく納得いきますね
ブッダの話は とかね 悟ってるはずなんで
それだったら 私だったら２行読んだだけでも汗が出ますけどね
これは人に説明しちゃうとどれほど難しいかと
この中身 いまだに私は説法しようとはしたことはないんです
でも 日本ではみんな仏教に出会い
出会いのは最初はスッタニパータですからね
これはアビダンマでもうどうにもならんですと思いますけどね
それはちょっと冗談で言ったことで
あの そういうもう 信じられないほどにも
雲の上の存在のような
もう天才みたいな善人たちもお釈迦様にあって
ほんの二 三分で会話して悟って帰る
また他の人々も見たんですね
あの先生に弟子入りして話を聞く
この先生に弟子入りして話を聞く
また別な先生の弟子入れて話をして話を聞く
これでいろんな宗教を聞いて
いろんな修行方法を聞いてもらって
いろんな哲学を聞いてもらって
やがてもうどうにもなくなっちゃうんです
迷ってしまうんです そういう人々
お釈迦様に出会った瞬間
お釈迦様はすべて迷い解決して見せたんです
では 具体的な例を出します
これは修行行者たちの話ではなくて
在家の方々の話で この
どこでしたっけ？ネッカ章なんですけど
カーラム系族って村のね
カーラムという民族のところで
カーラムで村の名前ですね
で そちらにお釈迦様が行ったんですね
行ったら このカーラム村の人々はもううんざり
何かある宗教のグループが来たんだということで
なぜうんざりかというと
訪ねては来るわ 訪ねては来るわ
いろんな宗教から 来てごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ
もうわけもわからないことを喋るわ
神のことやら 魂のことやら
もう来世のことやらとかね
そこで一つのグループ説法して帰ったら
また別なグループが入るでしょうし
そちらは前の人々の教えをくたくたもう批判してもう壊す
あんなのは全く間違っている
正しいのは私の教えだよと
それ言った間もなくまた別なグループが入り込んで
あの教えは全部ダメですね
あんなのは 正しいのは我々の教えだよと
そういう風に このほとんど毎年毎月何人かの宗教家が来て
もうあまりも強烈で 自分の教えを正当化して喋るんだと
だから あの人言ったことはこの人はダメというし
この人ということは別な人はダメというし
その人言ったことはまた別の人ダメというし
お釈迦様にはっきり正直に言ったんです
お釈迦様 我々はもううんざりやと
誰も信じられませんと
この宗教家っていう人々は
ただ お釈迦様の大義説法は何なのかと
お釈迦様 この人 カーラムたち
君らは見事です 疑うのは当たり前です
君だって君たちの態度
態度は そういう風に言われると
もう誰にも何が何か分からないのは当たり前でしょうと
だからこれから君たちで考えなさい
何が良いか 何が悪いか
自分たちで考えなさいという説法をしたんです
それで村の人々はみんなその話終わると仏教になってるんです
それから極端な論理を語り続ける論者たち
これすべて具体的なケースたくさんあります
ブッダの生涯すべて喋らなくちゃいけないんだから
その場合はね これできません
で 極端な理屈 論理喋る人々が来たら
お釈迦様は一言葉でもう壊してもう真理を教えてあげる
パターン化された人生に呆れた人々
ん？このパターン化された人生っていうのは
大体豊かな人々なんですよ
豊かな人々になってくると
もう毎日同じことをやるだけの人生で
お祭りに参加するわ まああれこれとか
朝起きてくるときちんと丁寧に食事を用意しているわ
それでお祭り気分で座ってご飯食べるわ
それ終わるとまた誰か友達と喋ってるわ
次にご飯食べるわ すぐに夜食べるわ
また音楽聴くわとかね
これって結局飽きちゃいますよ
ある若い人 若者がやさというものすごい金持ちなんです
あの草履は金で作ってるんです
金の草履しか履きません
で 一人息子で まあ両親にとってはもう息子は宝物で
贅沢三昧で育てたんですけど
息子が飽きちゃったんですよ
なんてこの刑務所にいるような生き方やと
これって人生かと 夜家出たんです
はぁ 刑務所に住んでる人みたいなもんだなとかね
家出してもう家を出たら家からね
なんて楽しいだなと なんかもう独り言
夜中歩くとお釈迦様そこら辺に夜座っていらっしゃったんです
お釈迦様は一言葉 そうよ
自由な生き方っていうのは大変楽しいですよと
言った途端 なんか自分の気持ちわかってる人がいるんじゃないかと
束縛されてない生き方こそ自由で楽しい究極の楽しみだよと言ったら
さっさとお釈迦様のそばに座って話をしたんです
それでその人は悟り開ける
朝起きてみたら 家の大事な息子がいない
もうどうなっているのかと
王子様みたいに育てた子供だから
探しても探してもない
それでもどうしようもなく
お城から外に出てあちこち見ると
どうせ金の草履を履いて靴履いて出ていくんだから
金属っていうのはかなり硬いでしょうし
足跡見えるんですね まあ幸いなことにアスファルトはなかったんだから
当時 足跡を見たら この靴はうちの息子の靴だからっていう
足跡を通っていったんです
言うと お釈迦様はどうせ家からね
探しに来るんだぞっていうことをわかっていたんだからね
そのヤツさんに君ちょっと隠れていなさいと
隠しておいたんです とは別に
ちょっと隠れてなさいと
父親が来るんです そしたらお釈迦さんに
お釈迦様はうちの息子を探してますけど
ここまで足跡がありますから
ここら辺にいるんでしょうかと
そうしたら あ まあそのうち会うでしょ
君はまあまあ落ち着いて座ってください
足跡もあるんだから 別にね
まあまあ まあ落ち着いて座って座って
お釈迦様 じゃあそのうちはいますからと言ったところで
お父さんがすごくほっとして
ちょっと世間話したんです
お釈迦様と おそらく息子の問題は語ったと思いますよ
どんな育て方したんでしょうかとかね
どんな生活させたのかとかね
それでそういうことが人間には絶えらない苦しみだよと
あんた方は子供にさせたのは
教えたら もうなるほど
言うこと いいことを教えてくれるんだと
で そのお父さんが仏教徒になるんです
仏教徒になって お釈迦様に起用して
言われると息子が後ろから来るんです
でお父さんが喜んで もう厳しいことを言う必要はないし
お釈迦様の説法されましたから
では家に帰ろうよと そしたら息子はいい
私は自由な道を選びますと
ちゃんとお父さんに断って
そのまま出家する でお父さんは何の反対もなく
君が選んだ道は正しいと
で 一人息子を出家させますよ
だから この それもパターン化された人生の例で
それでバラモンたちもいましたしね
もう伝統的な知識ばっかり積み重ねて
なんだか何がなんだかわからない
そういうバラモンたちは次から次へとお釈迦様に会って
自分の教えもちゃんと解明してもらって
仏教になってしまう それからこの桁違い
天才的な知識能力あったサーリプッタ
モッガラーナ ブッダの話の 1 行聞いて悟るんですよ
これは普通の人間にはできることじゃないんです
たった 1 行だけ聞いただけで
あ これが真理やと だからこの極端なインテリというか
極端な天才的な人 二人なんです
すぐお釈迦様に会うと
お釈迦様は対比説法して
それを悟り開かせてみせる
それで皆様知っていること
2 行の文句も覚えられない
学問に向いてない人 あのパンタカというね
あの叔父さんのところに出家して
なかなか勉強できない
3 ヶ月間経ったのに 2 行覚えられない
忘れちゃう だから頭が悪いというと
もう信じられないほど頭が悪い
学問はできん で おじいさんは阿羅漢ですけど
君は君には仏教は向いてない
だから家に帰りなさいと
もう離される でも仏教はすべての人に向いてるはずなんです
一人も向いてない人はいるはずがないんです
そこでお釈迦様は 朝早く
朝早くその人に会って
午前中になる前 午前中で完全に悟り開かせてみせたんです
お釈迦様は知ってる この子はね
こんな難しいバーリアがね
そんなのはもう向いてないし
でも人間には苦しみがあるでしょうに
だからある修行を教えたんです
君はこれやってくださいと
それやって 何のこともなく見事に 11時ぐらい 11
時半  11時ぐらいになってくると完全悟り開いているんです
それから どうかなんか悪いことをしたがるコーサラ国王がいたんです
お釈迦様の仲良しですけど
説法を聞いていく途中でなんかやっちゃいます
政治家は政治家なんです
国土を広げようと結構頑張りましたし
いろんなもう政治的な悪いことやら工夫やら
いろんなことをやらくりやってて
もうお釈迦様ってもうまあもうどうしようもないもう王様でしたかもしれませんだけど
でも あれこれやると政治的なからくりやったり
もうもうもういろんな工夫したりする孝祖王様さえも
お釈迦様にはもう完全にもう消して話を聞く
それからビンビサーラ王様っていうのは
政治よりも平和で安穏でいたいと思っていた
すごく落ち着いていた王様で
それでそのビンビサーラ王様の息子アジャータサット
父親を殺しちゃったんですよ
殺しちゃって悩んで悩んで悩んで
なんていうことをしたんですかと
あれほど欲のない父親をなんで殺したんでしょうかと
で いてもたってもいられないところでお釈迦様を見ただけで
あの苦しみが消えちゃったんです
でお釈迦様は何をしたかというと
このアジャセ王っていうのは
お釈迦様から見れば息子ぐらいの年下でした
下でしたけど で 王になってからもう後でお釈迦様に会いますね
そこまでは顔も合わせなかったし
大仏だったの仲間でしたし
でも父親のことを悩んで悩んで悩んで
なんて素晴らしい父親でしたか？と
私のことをどれほど心配してくれたでしょうかと
もうその人はいないと
そういうところに行ったら
お釈迦様を見たら また父親の代わりというかね
形見というか そういうふうな存在で見えたんです
お釈迦様は でお釈迦様とビンビサーラは年ほぼ同じで
出家する以前からのずっと友人なんです
そこでビンビサーラ王様のことだったら
お釈迦様はもう全部知り尽くしているし
それで父親の代わりに
ではお釈迦様の父親にして面倒見てあげるぞということで
もうすごい最大の仏教に貢献したんです
それから まあちょっと政治的な話をちょっと続けますけど
この民主主義国家もありましたから
インドで当時でも そのワッジ国にマッラ国
共和国 それで民主 ビンビサーラ王様
コーサラ王様って民主主義国家じゃないんですよ
王権王政だから なのにお釈迦様は何のことなくマッラ国に行ってワッジ国で堂々と政治やら全部語ってあげる
そこで商人たちの中で有名なのはナーガピンディカですね
お釈迦様の信者さんの在家信者さんの第一人者
それからウィサーカというものすごい大富豪で女性なんですね
そういう人々にも会う間で
お釈迦様はこのスニータワッサカーラという名前で言っている不可触民族という
この人に顔を合わせていることさえも禁止されていた
別 掃除やってる人二人も出家されて悟らせたんです
そんな難しくはなかったんです
だからお釈迦様の説法の方法って何なのかと思いますかね
スッタニパータで出てくる哲学者たちやら
これ学問も何もないでしょうに
もうもうもうもう不可触民族やと思ってる人々二人でしょうに
では完全たる悟りを開いて
八十代の弟子の中にも入り入ってるんです
だから誰がお釈迦様に会おうと関係なく
お釈迦様は真理を教えてあげる
悟りの道を教えてあげる
苦しみをなくしてみせる
そこでこのただ田んぼを探していた
農民たち お釈迦様はそっちを行くんですよ
田んぼ 人々はね もう仕事をしていると
私は二つ例をちょっと単純に言います
一人の人がこの田んぼを作っている間で
お釈迦様は朝早く托鉢に出かけるんだから
その田んぼの方に行くんです
そっちに行ったっても托鉢は何にももらえません
そう言ったら ちょっと挨拶して
おはよう おはよう その人
お釈迦様に挨拶されたと
すごく喜んで おはようと言ったら
お釈迦様はどう？今日何やってるの？ちょっと喋って
また次の日行ってちょっと喋って
そういう風にもう何日かもその人と付き合ったんです
それただの農民で 何の知識人でもなんでもないんです
それでも種まく時であろうか
水をあげる時であろうか
その仕事あるたびにお釈迦様はちょこっと顔を出して挨拶をして帰る
一言葉交わして それでその方は方はなんかお釈迦様は私にすごく友達になってるんだと
だから どこかに出かけようとしたっても
ちょっと 私の方にも寄ってくるんだと
こちらにも寄ってお釈迦様が托鉢にいらっしゃるんだと
なんてすごい方が友達になったもんかなと
しかし 私に一回だけでも托鉢にご飯を差し上げることはできなかった
だから今度この稲を刈り取るしてから
盛大にお釈迦様にお食事をお布施しますと決めたんです
決めて喜んでいる間に
またお釈迦様が来る 来たらお釈迦様
私はこのまだまだ稲はこんな状態ですけど
ちゃんと稲刈りできるようになったら
まずお釈迦様にお布施をします
その時 私の家に 家というところではないんですけど
小さなハットですからね
私のところにもいらっしゃっていただければありがたいんだと
お釈迦様はちゃんと見て受けるんです
いいですよと 来ますと
それで安心したのはいいんだけど
ちゃんと稲刈りをする
その前の日が雨が降って洪水になって
全て流されちゃったんです
それでその人には信じられないぐらい苦しみが現れたんです
まず 1 年間の収入 食べるものはなくなっちゃった
借りた土地でしょう おそらく
もう借りた種でしょうし
おそらく それは経典で書いてない
それを植え 偉大なるお釈迦様に約束もしたし
あのお釈迦様も何のこともなく
自分の小さなあのハットの中にでもいいよ
行きますよと約束もしてくれたし
その人は倒れちゃったんですよ
苦しんで悩んで たった一晩で全てなくなっちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様は約束の日はちゃんと行ったんです
だから稲刈りして次の日だから
行ってもそうすると その人の苦しみはさらに最大限の
お釈迦様は約束通りに来ているのに
もうどうしようもない状態
でも顔を合わせることできなかったんです
家の中で 倒れちゃって立ち上がれなくて
で そこでその人がやっと生きる苦しみに出会ったんです
その農民のすごく自然に生きていた普通のおじいさんが
商人たちは生きる苦しみには結構出会ってますけど
そこでお釈迦様は友達だからね
もう誰にも断ることなく
何のことなく家の中に入って
その人寝込んじゃってるところに行って
で 話しかけたんです そんなもんだよ
人生っていうのは 突然期待しないもの
計画にないものが起きちゃいますよと
その時は人間っていうのは途方に暮れますよと
約束やら何やらと言ったっても
そんな守れたものではありませんと
でも君 知ってますか？と
なんでそんなに悲しいなのかと
それか あの田んぼに 水に流されたあの稲に
君がすっごく期待していたんだと
あれがまずかったんだと
この世の中で期待できるものっていうのは
たった一つ何一つもないんだと
自分の体さえも期待できんと
それを知っている人はそういうことを気にしないよと説法して
その人はそれで悟りますよ
苦しみの極端にどん底にいた人は
たっとお釈迦様と話す
言葉を交わして そういうふうな説法で
それから狩人 狩人も一人二人ぐらい仏教徒になった話があります
全く殺生する人々でしょ
軍人たち 戦争に行って人を殺して帰ってくるんですけど
何かあったらということでお釈迦様にあってに会って
ちゃんと悟り開けましたと
それからいろんな職人たち
職人っていうのはなんか変な人々ですね
自分の職業にもう凝っちゃって
他世界知らない で思い出す例は
ある金細工職人というかね
金細工するアクセサリー作る人
で これ家柄の職人で で
出家したくなっちゃったんですね
それで仕事を出家したんです
出家したらサーリプッタ尊者が
この人は毎日美人ばっかしに会っているんだと
金持ちの美人ばっかしに
だってアクセサリーはほとんどそういう人々が使うもんだから
それで金の細工だからね
もうそこら辺に普通の人にはできないし
だからこの人は美しか知らない
美知ることで苦は知ることはできなくなるんです
だから悟れない こいつは
苦を知らないと だから生きる体っていうのは美ではなくて
すごく不浄だと これ説得させてもらおうと思って瞑想を教えるんです
この人は真面目に瞑想するはするはどうも落ち着かない
全く進まない そこで諦めちゃって
私はどうせ頭いいわけじゃないし
この偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者のところに出家して
教えている これ以上先生もいないし
それで悟らないんだったら
もう自分には見込みがない
だから家に帰ってそこそこ仕事をして
お布施でもしていればいいんじゃないかなと諦めちゃったんです
帰ることにしたんです
還俗することに そこでじゃあ帰るぞと
でも喜んでじゃないんです
もう失敗して 人生 もう人生そのものにも大失敗
もう負け犬なんです やっぱり帰る前に
もうちょっとお釈迦様に
手を合わせましょうと
言うと お釈迦様のところに行ったんです
行ったら なんか変な顔で苦しんで苦しんでる人を見たら
お釈迦様がいらっしゃいと呼んで
君 なんか随分嫌な顔してますけど
なんでそんなに嫌な顔してるんですか？と
そしたら 実は私はもう負け犬で
偉大なるサーリプッタ尊者のところに出家しても
微妙にでも心は育たなかったんですと
だから見込みはない なんで人間に生まれたんですか？と
と思ってるんだと だから
お坊さんたちに迷惑をかけてはいけないんだから
家に帰るつもりでいるんだと
お釈迦様は何のことなく
君 家であなたどんな仕事をしてたんでしょうかね
今 家に帰る 仕事をしなくちゃいけないし
そしたら聞いたら 私は金の細工職人で
宝石アクセサリーとか作っていたんだよと
ああ そう ということで
お釈迦様のそばにいろいろ花がありました
その中 ものすごく美しく咲いているハスの花があって
お釈迦様それを手に取って
きれいに持ちなさい で
あげると もう帰る人だからね
お釈迦様の手からね もう花一つもらうっていうのは大変なことでしょうし
で じゃあこれもらって
もうちょっとそこら辺座っていて
後で まあまだ時間がありますから
まあ家に帰るまではそんな急がなくてもいいでしょう
ちょっとそこら辺座っていてください
呼びますからと ちょっと待ってもらったんです
あの人はあのハスの花を持って
そこら辺でお釈迦様からちょっと離れて座って
またお釈迦様に呼びかけるんだからね
ありがたく待ってるんです
待ってる やることないんだから花を見てるんですよ
花を見ていると この職人だからキューッと心が集中しちゃったんです
ずっと美しいものを見て
いかに美しくするかっていう仕事をしてきたから
やったことはないんだから
花は花なりに自然にバランスを整えて
なんと美しくできているんでしょうかと
って集中力が生まれたんです
それで我を忘れてハスの花を見ているんです
でも あの当たり前のことで
花っていうのはね まあすぐしぼむでしょう
ゆっくりとしぼんでいくんですね
これを微妙に見ているんだから
これ明確に見えるんですよ
それであの花びらがしぼんで
もうなんとかなんとベタベタ倒れると同時に
この人の心から全部煩悩がなくなって悟り開くんです
だから仏教にはこの失格の人っていうのはありえないんです
ちゃんとお釈迦様がその人にも
あの苦しみのどん底の時
その苦しみに応えてあげたんです
それでその人は悟り開くんです
また この次に この素晴らしい芸術は天国の道だと思っていた芸人
芸人の話 それは ある芸人がいて
いろんな芸を見せるんです
舞台芸とかね かなり上手なんですよ
大勢の人々が来て この人の芸を見るんです
この人は職人だから すごい真剣で
私の芸を見て 大勢の人々は喜びを感じている
大勢の人々の苦しみが
私の芸を見るとなくなる
みんな笑って楽しむために私のところに来る
だから 私の仕事はただの芸人というよりも人救いだと
人助けているんだ 私は
ソクラテスや宗教家にもできないことをやっている
真剣に思ってるんです
だからものすごく真剣に芸をいつでも見せるんです
いい加減で遊び半分でそれはない
すごい真剣 人間を喜ばせてあげなくちゃいけない
それでもって人間が苦しみがなくなる
それでもって人間が笑う
泣いてる涙が消える で
心の安らぎを味わう だから私は真剣勝負に頑張らなくちゃいけないと
だから本人がそう思って
自分が人々に喜びを与えている
自分がこの芸で天国に行くんだと
だから そうやって正直に芸を見せる人々は行く天国がありますよっていう話で
その時 お釈迦様はその人のところに行ったんです
行ったらお釈迦様は別に芸を見せる必要はないし
ただちょっと話をしたんです
実際 お釈迦様 私はこういう芸人で
こんな気持ちで 正直な気持ちでいつも毎日芸をやってます
それで我々の先生たちはこれぐらい真剣に献身的に芸をやると
天国に生まれ変われるんだと言って
この芸術家行く天国の名前まで言ったんです
ちょっと今思い出せませんだけど
お釈迦様どう思いますかね？お釈迦様はいろいろご存知ですから
その話どうでしょうかと
そしたらお釈迦様ね それは話はよしましょうよ
そんな話はと よしましょうと言ったよ
この人には他の話もできんし
また聞く やっぱりお釈迦様
やっぱり私はね 別の話をしようよと
３回目に聞くんですね
３回目に聞いたら お釈迦様はいきなりあんたね
ブッダがもう３回断ったんだと
如来は それでもあんた聞くんだと
では聞きなさい 答えますと
あんたはね 天国ではなくて地獄に落ちるんだと
この地獄もこういう地獄だよと全部説明してあげたんです
人の欲を膨らましてあげて
幻覚を見せちゃって 芸術の幻覚だからね
全部騙しでしょ 幻覚を見せて
人々に生きる執着を増やしてあげて
あんた方はこんな風な苦しむ
これぐらい寿命もある
こういう地獄に落ちますよと
で この人は意識がなくなって倒れちゃったんです
お釈迦様の話を聞いて
で また意識戻って もう泣き崩れているんです
お釈迦様 あえてその人は悩みがなかったでしょうに
増しちゃったんです そこで意識戻って
もう泣き崩れて もうどうにもできなくなっちゃっていると
今まで 自分の人生って何でしたかと
先生たちが自分に何を教えてきたのかと
この人がもう全身で一生芸術に命かけてたんですよ
他何も知らない これこそ天国に行く道だと
で これから私はどうすればいいのかと
もう舞台劇もできないし
これからやってはいけないことで
とんでもないことだと
その人にはもう生きることもできないほどすごい精神的な状態にかかったんです
でも私はお釈迦様がそんなことなく
まあまあそんな気にしなくても
人間の道はそちらにあるんじゃないんだよと
人間が言葉で良いことを語って
頭で良いことを考えて
体で良いことをつけて
で 幸福を欲をなくしてとか
どんどんどんどんと探してあげたんです
その場で悟って出家する
全然時間かからなかったんです
それで遊女たちいてね
あとアンパパーリ スリマもすごい有名
アンパパーリっていうのはもうかなりの大金持ちで
彼女を見たら男たちは頭がおかしくなる
だから警備がいないと外へ出られないんです
いろいろいろんなところ書いて
みんなこのなんか変になっちゃうんだと
時々ご飯食べてる人でも
もしアマパーリがそこへ出ていくのを見たら
いきなりご飯があっちこっち捨てちゃって踊り出したりするんだと
それぐらい美人なんです
だから王様がちゃんとあの法律的に守ってあげて
まあ警備隊もつけることになって
もう金持ちだから でも
彼女はやっぱり人生は苦しいんだと
こんな言い方と でお釈迦様から説法を聞いて
夜中に悟って 仏教にはもうすっかりちゃったんです
大きなお寺も作って寄付したんです
このパターチャーラという女性がね
子供 家族 旦那さん みんな亡くなっちゃって
1 日でね 頭が狂っていて
お釈迦様のたった一言葉で正気に戻って
それから出家して悟り開いて
大弟子サーリプッタ目連尊者
お釈迦様の一番左と右の大弟子でしょ
パターチャーラは女性の一人なんだなったんです
もともと頭狂ってたんですけどね
それぐらい育てられたんです
で それから年順で考えてみると
今言ったのはだいたい年の人々でしょ
でも子供でもそれたもんじゃないんですよ
このソーパーカっていう子供がいたんですよ
お母さんが亡くなって
他の 2番目の奥さんもらっちゃって
で その奥さんがこの子供をいじめていじめて
もう育てない それで喧嘩しちゃって
父親にこいつはとんでもない子だから捨てなさいと
父親はしょうがなく自分の我が子を捨てたんです
それで家に戻れないように
もうすごく遠く連れて行って
夜森の中で遺体捨て場に子供をそのまま捨てて帰っちゃったんです
帰るんだから もう 7歳ぐらいの年でしたからね
それなりに遺体に縛っておいたんです
まあこちらちょっと待って
もうもうどこか行っちゃったら困りますからとかね
見つからないんだからと言って
なんとごまかしたでしょう
言って遺体につけておいたんです
捨てている 父親の狙いは自分では殺せないんですね
子供は いくら奥さんの機嫌を取ろうとしたっても
自分には子供は殺せないし
まあ夜狼やらね 狐やら来るんだから
その時ついでに食っちゃうでしょうし
この子も どうせ腐ってる肉よりは生の方が美味しいということで
そこで父親が子供を遺体につけて出て行っているところを見て
お釈迦様が夜そちらに行ったんです
自分一人で って子供が泣いているところで全部保護して縛ってあったものはね
じゃあ帰りましょう をつなげて帰ったんです
お寺へ だからお釈迦様と手をつなげて
じゃあ帰りましょうと言ったあの一言葉で
その子はそれでもう何の恐怖感も何もなく
喜んでお寺に入って それで出家して
ものすごい年下で悟るんですよ
でも比丘戒は二十歳にならないと授けれない
授けることはできない
お釈迦様は特別扱いしていたんです
この子供に ちっちゃい子供なんですけど
お釈迦様の話を聞いて完全に悟り開いていて
そこである日 お釈迦様が子供を呼んで質問するんです
一は何なの？とか 二は何なのかと
みんな聞いてるんです
お釈迦様は遊んでるでしょとみんな思ってたんですよ
この子供と でも一は何なのかと聞いたら
この子供の答えは違う
二は何なのかというと
ナーマとルーパだよと
子供は子供なりに答える
名色ですよと では三は何なのかと
三というのは苦 楽と不苦不楽の十です
三つの十だと子供が答える
それで十まで聞くんです
十は答えられません 悟ってないと
お釈迦様すごいと 見事ですと
君は 君は今日から比丘だよと
沙弥を入れて比丘にするんです
で それは大胆なことで
まだ十歳にもなってないのに
例えばもう三十歳 四十歳に後から出家する人々は
あのお坊様に頭を下げて礼をしなくちゃいけないんだから
それ子供 それで若い者の中では
このヤサ アヌルーダ ボーディラージュクマーラ
いろいろ若者たちが またハッタカ
アーララカ ものすごいたくさんいます
大体若者の方が数が多かったんですけど
いろんなことで出会って
一回でもう仏教の世界に入り込んで幸福を味わう
ものすごいたくさん このボーディラージュクマーラというのは王子ですけどね
おかしい人で子供がいないんです
とにかく子供が欲しくて欲しくて
それで新しくお城を作って
で これ子供がないのは
何か自分たちに徳が足らないんだからと
だからお釈迦様にこの家を最初に使うことをお釈迦様にお布施して
祝福してもらうと そうするとお釈迦様が子供を授かるではないかと言って
もし自分たちに子供が授かるならばということで
お釈迦様がこの布を踏んで家に入る
お城に入るでしょうと
お釈迦様が入る玄関からお座りになるところまで
ずっと白い布をずっと敷いてあったんです
ある意味ではこれすごい贅沢です
当時のインドではね 信じられないほど
でお釈迦様はこの若夫婦
のからくりはもう知ってるんです
この若夫婦は子供がないことに困っている
いくら王子であろうとも
やっぱりこれがね 問題があるんですよ
人間だから 王子でよかったと
お城も新しいお城も作って
なんて羨ましいかと我々は思うかもしれませんだけど
この若夫婦にとっては地獄の苦しみなの
お城があるんだけど バカでかくて
子供はいないんだから
召使いばっかしで面白いことは何ともないんです
でお釈迦様は玄関に来て
この王子呼ぶんです 本人を
ご主人を 君 こちら来てください
と言ったら はい 何でしょうかと
お釈迦様 この布はね これ畳んでおきなさい
どうすることもできないし
どうせこれ仕来りでしょうし
偉い方が来るとね まあ王家の場合はね
まあ白い布を敷いておくんです
畳んでおきなさいと 言うと
こう見て もうしょうがない
畳んでおいたんです で
しかし 本人がすごくショック受けちゃったんです
そこで で ショック受けちゃって
王子様だから まあちゃんとお釈迦様のお席を全部割って座って側に聞いたんです
なんでお釈迦様はああいう
ちょっとそれはちょっと変なことなんですけど
何でしたんですか？と言ったら
お釈迦様はね あんたね
そんな布を敷いておくっていうのは
こんなのはもうごく普通なことでしょ
でもあんた何か企んでたんではないかと
それでもバレちゃって
まあ実は私たちに子供が授かるならば
お釈迦様がこの布の上に歩いていただけるでしょうと私は思ったんだと
と思って 布以外歩けないようにしておいたんです
だから いかに子供が欲しいかっていうことでしょ
それでお釈迦様はあえて大胆に畳みなさいと
これは言うと どれほどショックを受けますかね
若夫婦は これはお釈迦様の断言だから
あなた方には子供はないと
それでも頭がおかしくなっちゃって
もうもう一番期待することは得られない
お釈迦様説法するんですよ
その時 その説法を聞いて
またその人もちゃんと仏教徒になって悟りもゆるかには悟りましたけどね
そういうことである いくらでもあります
皆様は知ってる？病気に
それから若者の例で それからセーラ
バラモンの話は結構聞いた方がいいんですよ
セーラっていうバラモンがいて
90歳も富んでいるんです
そのインドではもう とっても有名
第1番目 バラモン人の中でも長老中の長老
並大抵の人ではありません
彼も聞いたんです お釈迦様というすごい人がいるんだと
聞いたところで やっぱり会わなく
会いたくなったんです
会いたくなったんだけど
会えないんです 状況上は
この人はもう誰に 2番目
国王に 2番目かもしれませんだけど
すべてのバラモン人の中では長老なんです
だからバラモン教の長老中の長老がいて
出て行ってお釈迦様に会うと
これちょっとまずいと
それでも本人がやっぱりそれでも会う資格があるならば
会って何が悪いんですかと
で 弟子たちに頼んだんです
君たちは釈尊に会いなさい
会って調べなさい 私のような人が行って挨拶したっても構わない人格者なのかと
弟子たちはまあちゃんと調べて
それはそれはもう先生が会った方がいいとと報告する
そこでものすごい大勢で隠れてじゃないんです
大胆に大々的に で みんなバラモンたちも連れて行って
すごくお年なのに お釈迦様のところに行って
足を触って礼をする 礼をして
その場をお釈迦様の威厳
あの智慧 あの偉大なる方
そこはもうそのバラモン人にはお釈迦様の本当の姿で見えるんです
お釈迦様は見せるんです
私はもうただ子供やらいうふうに
そんなことで そんな人間でもありませんよっていうこと
そこを見て このセーラバラモンが入ってきた言葉を言うんですよ
釈尊は世界支配する王になるべきでしょう
と言ったら 何のことなくラージャハマスミセーロという風にお釈迦様は答えてくるんです
私はもうすでに王様だよと
すべての煩悩に打ち勝っているんだと
最高の勝利を得ているんだと
知るべきものは知っている
やるべきものはやっている
苦しみは完全に消している
究極な平安安らぎを体験している
だから私こそ王様だよと
で もうセーラさんも長い
もうもうもうインテリのインテリだからね
すごい美しい文章でお釈迦様を讃嘆して讃嘆して仏教徒になって帰るんです
まあ他のアングリマーラの話はみんな知ってるし
アングリマーラは殺人鬼で
お釈迦様に会った途端すべてやめたでしょ
孝祖王様さえも怯えていたのに
なんだあのやり方はと
それで今度インドに行ったら
このガイドさんが教えてくれた
お釈迦様に対するエピソードがいろんなところでかぶれて伝わっているんです
で 全部パーリ文献に残っているわけでもない
で 彼がそういう一つエピソードを教えてくれたんです
お釈迦様がアングリマーラに
まあまあ一応お釈迦様を殺しに来たんだから
これはもうできなくて
もう説法を聞こうという状態でしょうに
そうすると アングリマーラ君
あの木から葉っぱ 1枚取ってこいと言ったんだそうです
言ったら はい わかりましたと言って葉っぱ 1枚取ってきたんです
木から 木から取ってくるのを見たら
あれはこれはあかん 返せなさい
戻しなさいと 元に あれ
これはあかん 木に戻しなさいと言ったら
アングリマーラがもうもう人殺しちゃっても馬鹿ではなかったんだから
かなり頭がいい人でしたしね
これが驚いちゃって お釈迦様
これはもう元に戻せませんよと
だったらね 人の命取るなよ
それは元に戻せませんよと
というふうに答えたんです
一旦命を奪ったらね 元に戻せません
元に戻せないものはやるものじゃないんだと
そういうエピソードもあって
まだ別ないろいろちゃんとした記録はパーリ経典にありますからね
だからまあ信じられないほど人を殺して殺したいと
でもお釈迦様会っただけでチャッタ人
会話はそれではなかったんですけど
お釈迦様に止まれ 待て待てと言ったでしょうね
あれ 日本から学んでいるんでしょうかね
日本で誰か泥棒でも誰でも追いかけてると
待て待て 待とうわけないでしょうに
で お釈迦様は先に歩いていたんですから
待てと言ったし お釈迦様
いえ 私は待っていますけど
君も待ったらどうでしょうかっていうことで
彼が心が変わるんです
これで逆にジャイナ教の人々は普通の生蜜飲まない
命があるんだからこれ殺生やと
そういう人々にお釈迦様は教えを教えてあげるんです
で 次 神様は信仰していたね
信仰心 絶対的神様を信じていた
今 キリスト教 イスラム教みたいに
そういう人々はお釈迦様に会ったところでたちまち神様忘れちゃいます
で カースト制度は神の決まりだと社会差別を認めた人々
あるバラモン 何人かが来て
こんなのはもうもうしょうがないのではないかと
バラモン人は神様の口から生まれているんだと
それお釈迦様の答え知ってますかね
あ そうですかと 私たちは人間というのは女性の生殖器官から生まれると知ってますけど
君らの神様の口はそういうものですかと
場所がちょっと違うんじゃないかと
だから馬鹿にしちゃったんですね
神様の口は何なのかと
それからシガーラっていうのは人がね
それまたいくらか若者でね
どうしようもない人間でしたしね
だから一応父親が亡くなった時はね
六法ぐらい来やしなす言ったんだから
行ったんだからやるっていう
現代人とまるっきり同じなんです
マニュアルにあるんだからやると
何にも理解もわかりも何もないというつまらない人生ですけど
みんなやるからやると
みんなピアスつけちゃうと
まあじゃあ私もとかね
そういう現代人っていうのは
みんなもうみんなやるからやるだけの人生で
もうすっごいつまらないと思いますけど
でもみんな面白いと思ってるらしいですね
本人たちは シガールにはね
やるからやるんじゃないよと
物事には意味があるんだよと教えてあげたでしょうね
六法来経っていうのはその経典なんです
それで終わらなかったんで
日々お釈迦様は毎日町ばたでいろんなところで人に毎日会うんですよ
会う会う人に何か教えるんです
はい 次に   何と言いましょうか
堕落に陥る道を教えてくださいと頼む人もいたのです
だってお釈迦様は幸福の道ばっかり教えてるでしょうに
この人は私にはね この堕落に陥る道を教えてくださいと
お釈迦様教えたんです
それでその人堕落になったと思いますか？いえ
見事だった お釈迦様っていうのは
天国に行く道を教えてくださいって言ったら
これ完璧に教えるし では地獄に落ちる堕落する道を教えてくださいと言ったら
これ見事に完璧に教えてくれるんだと
こんな智慧のある人を信仰するしかないんじゃないかといって出家徒になるんです
ブッダに出会って幸福を掴んだのは人間だけではありません
神々はもちろんのこと
ナーラーギリ パーリリーなどのゾウさえもお釈迦様にあって心安らぎを味わった
味わったんです いろいろ動物たちの話もあります
たとえ動物であっても
ブッダに触れると幸福になるのです
ブッダが苦しみをなくす手にするんです
一人の動物の中で一番小さいあてにならない動物というのはカエル１匹なんです
これちゃんとエピソードを記録しています
ある一匹のカエルがまあ餌でも取ろうかなと思ったところで
そこら辺に比丘たちが集まっていて
お釈迦様は説法を始めたんです
そこでそのカエルはその声耳に入っちゃって
お釈迦様の声にはある響きがあるんです
とにかくその響きが入ると
ものすごく あの 何機能と言うんですか？ヒアリング
みんな落ち着くんです
カエルはもう動き身動きできなくなっちゃって
全部足も全部畳んでじーっとその音を聞いてたんです
先生わからない内容は
そこに来たある在家の人が
まあもう話聞こうとかなと思って
自分の杖をそちらに刺して
もうこうやって話を聞こうと思ったら
猿のもう背中の上 そのまま潰れちゃったんです
カエルが でもたちまち天国に生まれちゃったんです
天国に生まれてみたらびっくり
どうなってるんでしょうかと
それで見たら 自分がもうほんのちょっと前にカエルでしたと
ただ虫食ってるちっぽけなカエルが
なんでこんないきなりすごい神になったのかと思ったら
これはお釈迦様のおかげだと
これにはしっかり礼をしなくちゃいけないということで
みんなに見えるように降りてきて
お釈迦様に礼したら 君誰ですか？と
お釈迦様知らないし そしたら実は死んでるカエルは私ですよと
それからまあ普通の説法を聞いて帰りましたし
神になってから悟る人は悟るんですよ
カエルは悟りませんだからね
そう悟れると言っちゃうと皆様に失礼でしょうしね
もう一つ この動物なんですけど
これがもう神話的に書いてます
そうでなきゃ話が通じませんけど
龍というか ナーガですね
ヘビなんですね 仏教が気に入っちゃって
動物の世界は嫌で サンガの世界にいるんだそうと
出家世界に品格のある
何も罪を犯さないということで
もう勝手にこの蛇がもうお坊さんぶってやってるんで
お坊さんといるところでいるわ
で あんまりもうお坊さんたちもあまりに気にしなかったんですけど
やっぱりこれがちょっと迷惑だと
うちらっちゃって ヘビがもう転がっちゃって
そこら辺にいつでもいるんだから
追い出しても出て行かないし
夜になってくると光もないんだから
踏んじゃったらまた大変危なくて困るし
でお坊さんたちも困ってどうしようかと
このヘビはなかなかもうお坊さんたちいるところから出ていかない
本人が出家してるつもりなんです
そこでお蛇さんと会話できませんだからね
お釈迦様は一応心に通じるようにコミュニケーションできますから
君は蛇の仲間に入りなさいと
この修行できるのは人間ですよと
だからこれからは悪いことをしないで生活で
死んでからいいところに生まれ変われば修行できるでしょうと
今回は失格だよと 言うとものすごく悲しくなっちゃって
もう泣いたという話なんですけど
デーヴァダッタなんか分かりませんですけど
それでもお釈迦様は慰めてあげてね
気にすることはありません
今は君もすごく心清らかにしてけると
まあ出家するでいるんだからね
だから必ず救われますよと
ということで慰めて帰してあげたんです
うん そういうことで  動物の話は
まあ思い出すともうきりがなくありますけどもね
とにかく動物全員お釈迦様のことはすごく好きでしたし
ナーラギリっていうのは
あのデーヴァダッタがね
酒飲んで飲ませて飲ませて酔わせちゃって
蹴ったり いろんな厳しくもうもう激怒させちゃって
頭をおかしくさせて道路に追い出しちゃったんです
お釈迦様が出て前に もう何でも食らうんで
戦争を訓練している象だから
そういうことやられちゃうと何でも食わす
お釈迦様をそれでもう暗殺させようという企みでしたけど
みんな逃げたんです アーナンダ尊者がお釈迦様は殺されたらとんでもないことだから
自分が先に行ってもうもう身代わりになるするんです
でお釈迦様 アーナンダ尊者
みんな逃げてるんだからね
君も後ろに下がったらどうですか？と
そこでお釈迦様の命令だから
アーナンダ尊者が後ろに下がるんです
そこであるお母さんが子供を抱っこして抱いていて
もう逃げ切れなくなっちゃって
お釈迦様を見たんですね
見たらなんとかなるんじゃないかということで
そのまま子供を置いておいて
もう自分逃げちゃったんです
でないと 象の足は結構幅が大きいんだから
それまた普通の象じゃないんです
かなり大胆なバカでかい象です
それで女の人が逃げるのを見たら
象がちらっと見たんで
赤ちゃんを それ潰そうとそちらに行くと
お釈迦様はなんのことなく象を呼ぶんですよ
そっちじゃないでしょ？名前で名前は知ってましたしね
こちらにおいでよと あれ？こちらにおいでよと
あれ？この一言葉で頭がじっと落ち着いちゃって
元に戻ったんです でお釈迦様と見て
お釈迦様も頭を触って
お前もううるさくて何やってるんだよ
おっちゃん おとなしくしなさいよと
マークンジェラナーゲマスドというあの偈がありまして
こんな大騒ぎしてうるさくしてはあかんよと
怒ったら格好悪いんだよと
大胆な人々は 偉大なる人々はそんな怒って踏ん張って
そんな汚いことはやらないんだよという偈なんです
それであの問題は解決したんです
だからお釈迦様の前で
あの一言葉で膝を折って崩れたあの象のあの姿を見た人間がみんなびっくり
みんな隠れて見ていたんだから
何の戦いも何もなかったんです
犬のようにお釈迦様のところにお座りしてたんです
前に だからそういうすごいブッダの力があるんです
で もう一つ関係ないエピソードなんですけど
ある日 お釈迦様が どこかへ出かけている時は
この羊飼いの人が羊の群れを持って餌を餌場にね
連れて行こうかなということで
川を渡そう 渡そうとするんですよ
川は水は浅いんでしたが
あの...なかなかこの羊たちは渡る気持ち
つもり 気持ちはそれほどない
で どういうことかというと
こちらでお母さんというメス羊がいて
子供がいるんで 子供は弱いんです
だからこのお母さんが全然川を渡る気持ちはないんです
それで羊飼いっていうのは困っちゃって
羊っていうのはいつでも群れ一つにしておかないと
できないんですからね
もう頭が悪いんだから
何するか分からない どこに行くか分からない
それから失ってしまいもしれない
だから群れそのまま固めて川を渡してもらわないと
でもこのお母さんにはもう行かない
というのは 子供が弱いんだから
羊飼いもいろいろもう苦労して苦労するは苦労するはうまくいかないな
いくら叫んでも いくら叱っても
あれこれ脅してももう動かない
そちらにお釈迦様が来たんです
お釈迦様はそちらに来て
あの人に一言も喋らなかったんです
そのまま行って あのお母さんのところにいた子羊をお釈迦様は抱いて
自分で先に川を渡ったんです
何も一つも言わないで
でお母さんがお釈迦様が羊を子羊を抱いたんだから
あのお母さんの羊も何のことなく子供の口をつけながら後ろから行ったんです
そこで羊のグループさんともうここに行ったんです
行ったらお釈迦様は子供をポイと置いてそのまま行ったんです
それを見ていたあの人は
これが人間の道だと 何がわかったんです？物事は蹴っただけではうまくいかないんだと
心読むことやと このお母さんの心を読んでいなかったんですね
あの羊飼いは そこであの人はなるほど
これが人間の道だととわかったという話で
一応それでその 第3章は終わります
もう時間はないんです
ほんのちょっと休憩します
ということで いろんな人にお釈迦様があったりして
要はお釈迦様にはいろんな人がいます
会った人が自分の問題には解決法が見つかりますが
それは 2番 2つ そのステージで
まず日常的な苦しみ それから究極的な苦しみって全部なくなってしまったんです
失敗したケースはないんです
そこで第4章に入ります
なぜ成功したんですかと
大体失敗することもあるはずでしょうし
それはそんなに難しい話ではないんです
ブッダは苦しみを知り尽くしている
だから人の苦しみぐらいはね
苦しみ全体的に知り尽くしているんだから
ある人の苦しみぐらいは説明できるのは当たり前のことなんです
ですから 人の苦しみは痛いほどわかる
無明によって一切の生命は苦しんでいるから
悩んでいる人 失敗した人を責めない
貶さない これも一つポイントなんです
相手を貶さ 貶さないんです
人間 何か失敗して苦しんでいるんです
その上 あんたがなんでそんなことをやるんでしょうかとか
そんなことやったらあかんではないかとかね
そういうやり方をブッダの場合はないんです
人間っていうのはそんなもんだよ
アホなことしかことしかしないんだよという態度で喋るんです
だから人間は無明があるんだだから苦しんでいる
失敗もする 悩みもある
だから貶せないんですよ
非難できません 人を脅して侮辱して
この ２つに分けて 神を信じる人と信じない人とかね
信じる人には永遠な天国
信じない人は永遠な地獄とか
そういうふうな この脅して人をもうもう処分する思考っていうのはないんです
みんな同じでしょうと
そんなのはね 例えばアングリマナスいたっても
そういうちょっと頭が変わっちゃったんだから
たくさんの人を殺したってんで殺したんであってというか
態度で だからお釈迦様の態度というのは
私もかなり苦しんできた
しかし 解決方法を見つけたのです
君にもそれを教えてあげる
お釈迦様の態度はそういう態度なんです
人がすっごい人生に失敗して悩んできたら
別にあんたって何？本当に不幸なやつだなという態度ではなくて
やっぱり人間は無明があると煩悩があるとそうなりますよと
実は私もそんなもんでしたと
前は ということで教えてあげる
だから今は苦しみがない
今すごい幸せです で 君にも教えてあげますと
それはお釈迦様の成功の秘訣ですね
次に それは別な言い方で言えばね
失礼な態度で言えば 人の人の苦しみなんかは知れたものです
人の苦しみなんか知れたもんでしょう
驚くに値する 理解に苦しむ理不尽な苦しみなんかは存在しない
存在もしない 人間が苦しい苦しいと言うんですけどね
そんな知れたもんです
そんなの 一切の物事の根底にある法則
いわゆる因縁論を発見しているのです
お釈迦様がそれを発見しているんです
だから人間の苦しみなんか小さくちっぽけに見えるんです
なんだ こんなもんかと
たとえ時代が変わっても変わらないのは生きる苦しみだけなのです
時代が変わっても 人が変わっても変わらないのはたった一つ
生きる苦しみだけ変わらない
それでスライドを進めます
ドッカアリエサッチャという仏教の四聖諦の 1番目
苦聖諦の内容は昔も今もこれからも同じものなのです
お釈迦様は苦しみを知り尽くして
真理第 1号として説かれたんですよ
その真理第 1号に中身ありますよ
生まれること 老いること
病気になること 好きな人と別れること
嫌な人と付き合うこと
期待外れること なんとかなんとか
それが昔も今も同じなんです
内容 その内容に入ってない新種の苦しみは現代社会ではありません
新種のウイルスなんかはあるんだけど
新種の苦しみなんかはありません
全部型が古いんです 現代人は感染に対峙してして
決して苦しみもありません
科学発展でドッカサッチャの中で一部取りましたよと
それもないんです だからブッダが苦しみを知り尽くしている
言ってるポイントわかりますか？だから苦は何なのかとお釈迦様が説いたお経文句あります
その文句の内容 中身 昔も今も変わってないんです
今の苦しみも同じものなんです
それで昔なかった しかし
今がある 新しい苦しみなんかはありません
今の苦しみも全部昔もあった苦しみなんです
そこで我々 科学的に発展して
お釈迦様がおっしゃった愛別する苦痛がなくなってますかね
そのまんまでしょ 家の一軒ぐらい作って
たくさん友達を作れば
愛別する気なんかないんだぞとかありえないんです
だから人は聞く質問はいつでも同じものです
だから今も皆様の質問には答えられます
仏教から大胆なことを聞かない
知ってます それは アメリカ人であろうか
黒人であろうか アジア人であろうか
若者であろうが 学者であろうが
聞く質問は限ってるんです
本気で宗教に積極する質問は苦しみの質問だからね
人生の苦しみっていうことだからね
自分の悩みっていうことだからね
それはもう大体ワンパターンで質問が決まってるんだから
こちらで答えはもうとっくに昔からできてるんです
そういうことだから 仏教は時代遅れにはならないし
どんな人にもアクセスできる教えにもなっているんです
そこで第5章に行きます
随分早く進みます そんなスピードで最初から進みならかったんですけど
[咳] 実践も大器かなんと
これも考えるべきポイントなんです
自分に適した実践方法
耳障りの良いスローガンです
私に適した実践方法あるんだぞと言ったら
これ耳障りがいいんです
しかし 世間世界のいかなる調理方法を駆使しても
出来上がりはカレーになりますとはならないと思いますね
だから方法が変わっても結果が同じということはありえないんですよ
一応その例え話で言いたいことはすぐわかると思います
上の行でね 耳障りはいいんだけど
目指す結果は同じであるならば
その過程もプロセスも同じでなくてはならないのです
我々は苦しみをなくした状態を目指すならば
その方法も同じなんです
誰にでも 私にだけ特別なプロセスがあるわけじゃない
それだったらね どんな調理方法で料理を作ったっても
出来上がりはカレーになるんです
[咳] スライド変わります
で 問題に答えがあります
人の気分に合わせて答えを変えないのです
何か問題があると その問題に答えがあるんです
それは人の気分によって変わるっていうことはありえないでしょうに
2 たす 2 はといえば  4 という答えがあるでしょうに
それは田中さんの場合は ６ で
上村さんの場合は ８ でとかね
今日は土曜日だから 10 で
明日だったら 13 だよとか
そんなのありえないでしょうに
2 たす 2 は 4 という答えあるんです
もし大器的に答えを変えられるなら
その問題に実は答えがないということになります
何でもいいんだからっていうことだったら
答えがないんです  [咳] 説明しちゃうとちょっと哲学っぽくなりますから
抜けます 問題に答えは仏教では実践ということです
しかし その実践は実行できないとなると
その実践は問題に対する答えではありません
だから問題に問題というのは
人間の苦しみに対する答えは仏教の実践なんです
実践はわかっているんだけど
実行できませんよと言っちゃうと
それは答えじゃないんで
それだったら 実行できないものを言ったってもね
例えば飲めない薬あげたっても
病気治らない 治るわけないでしょうに
例えばがんになってる人の場合は
火星人が来て手当てするとがんが治りますよと
確実に 100%治りますと言っても意味がありますかね
だってどこから火星人捕まりますかね
私は今日一人見つけたんだから言ってますよ
あの 降りる すぐ見たんです
電車に人が看板書いて座ってます
か あの法被みたいな あれなんて言いますか
日本のあれ あちら宣伝いっぱい書いて
何がというと  UFO やら異星人に対する情報欲しい人は声かけてください
おそらく火星人だなと
でもこちらに来るのはもうすぐ降りると
もうちょっともう新宿の方で見つけたらね
良かったのに だから実践は実行できないんだったら
それは答えではありません
スライド変わります したがって
仏教の実践方法は大義的なものではなく
誰にでも試すことが確かめることができるものなのです
苦しみは誰にもあるんだから
それを乗り越えることも誰にもできる
だったら その方法は誰にも合います
わざわざと方法を変える必要ないんです
料理方法を変えちゃうと
料理自体変わっちゃうんですよ
結果変わりますから だから実践は大義的じゃないんです
と言っても失礼な言い方なんですけど
どちらでも言葉の遊びで
実践も大義的だと言えば大義なんですけど
でも人によって変えることはない
八正道 ヴィパッサナー
慈悲 基本的道徳などは男女
まあなんとか読めない
書いたんですけど まあ要約知識人
一般人 都会人 村の人 うんうん
そんなことはない 誰にでもできます
そんなのは 問題は信仰を持ってる人なのです
しかし 信仰を持っているとちょっと引っかかるところがあるんです
しかし 信仰さえも問わないのです
お釈迦様は君の信仰は何なのかと聞かないんだから
だから信仰もそのまま置いておいて
実践してみれば 自分の苦しみがなくなります
くだらんことをやりたければ
自分の宗教を続ければいいんです
宗教問題解決したという試しはないんだから
この世の中で宗教は人の苦しみ消した試しはないんだけど
戦争はいくらでも起こしたことはあるんです
人を殺した試しはいくらでもありますけど
人を助けたという例はないんです
それでも好きなものは好きだからしょうがないでしょうしね
だから宗教好きな人は宗教やってもいいんだけど
私は言いたいのは 君は好きだったらその宗教やってください
しかし 君の苦しみはそれで治らないんだから
この治療法をやってみてください
苦しみも治りますよと
それでやがて信仰を持つ愚かさに気づくから問題ないんです
この実践をやってみると
信仰も苦しみを作るものだとわかるんだからね
で 次のスライドに行きます
しかし 実践に実際に大器量性があるのです
大器量性もあるんです
それは個人の理解の仕方によるものです
ここら辺はものすごく難しいんだから
今日飛ばしたいという気持ちなんです
あの実践法を理解するとこ
理解の仕方があるんだからね
だからちょっと大器量性あるように見えます
これをオリエンテーションという言葉で理解すればわかると思います
私はこの非常に非常に美しいローマ字を選んでおいたんですけど
あのコンピューターで出てもないんです
これエル文字ですね オリエンテーションってどういう意味でしょうかね
例えば あるもう会社でもよろしいし
もう大学でもよろしいし
あちらこちらからいろんな人々が集める
集めてそこに入学して
それから活動しなくちゃいけない
それからみんなにまずオリエンテーションするんです
黒人にはそれなりに教えてあげて
白人にはそれなりに教えてあげて
中国人の留学生にはそれなりに教えてあげて
その言語も違うんです
その場合は それでオリエンテーションしてから
ではみんなで入学して頑張りましょうというところは同じなんです
違う言葉で言えば 世界のすべての料理を用意しているブッフェパーティー
スタイルだと理解しても構わない
わかりやすい例なんです
世界の料理全部合わせてブッフェパーティー作っちゃうと
国産はあらゆる料理作って置いておく
とにかく一人 1食しか食べないでしょうに
1食食べたら満腹でしょうね
だから自分に適した料理は必ずあるんです
だって世界の料理全部揃ってるんだから
その食食べればいい だから仏教の経典とか見ると大量にあるんですけど
どちらでも同じなんです
自分に適したものを繰り返して実践すれば見事にうまくいくんです
で それで第5章は終わります
短い章です で 第6章 で
解決する論 ブッダの解決策は 3種類です
1個人特有の悩み この場合は個人が努力する必要はあります
大体個人個人が悩みを持ってますからね
これ個人特有というのはおかしいんです
個人が気づいている悩み
子供の心臓のケースで言ったように
子供の心臓が弱ければ
その母親がそれに気づいている
愛する者から離れたくないという苦しみに出会っているだけ
お母さんわかってない
それが 子供の心臓が良くなかったら全てうまく行きますよと変なこと言ってるだけで
そこを直し上げればいいんです
お母さん これは愛する者から別れたくないという苦しみだよと
でもその子供には鉄でステンレススチールで心臓を作ってあげても死にますよと
本当にいうことを教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
だからこのとにかく個人の悩みにまず答え出す
その場合は個人が努力してそれを直さなくちゃいけないんです
2番目 個人の悩みかもしれませんが
原因は社会にあるかもしれません
悩みは自分のものなんですけど
原因は社会にある場合
どうしましょうかと これは社会の問題
お釈迦様それも教えています
社会人としての生き方
政治 経済のあり方なども教えられてあります
王様たちにした説法やら
いろんなところでそれも教えられてあります
すごい明確な政治論があります
経済論もあります はい
次  3番目 では  3つありますからね
最終的な解決方法 それは悟ることですね
生命として輪廻転生を繰り返している限り
いくら一時的な解決策を練っても終わりがないのです
また同じ問題が別な別な問題か
必ず現れるのです 一つ解決すると
別な問題が現れてくるんです
最終的に輪廻の問題を解決するのです
これも個人が行うべき実践なのです
2番目以外は個人やるんです
1と 3は  2番目はみんなでやらなくちゃいけない
だからジャータカ物語では政府が腐っていると
国民みんな政府を倒せというふうな物語は書いているんです
黙っているなよと だからみんなの問題です
それはみんなで解決しなくちゃいけない
集団解脱はあり得ません
集団結婚式とかあったようですけど
まあありえません はい
次 で それで仏教の最後の言い方
パッチャッタン見えません
パッチャッタンウェーリタッボウィンニューヒ
パッチャッタン各自で自分一人一人でウェーリタッバン体験するべき
理解するべきだよと ウィンニューヒっていうのは
智慧のある人々が 智慧のある人々が自分一人一人で
このブッダの真理を理解するべきですと
で 終わります それはあのソーさんです
ナーラーに入っとる スリランカの有名なお寺の壁画です
では ありがとうございます
ご質問などございますでしょうか
お釈迦様に会った人や動物なら全員
動物を除いて人間なら全員解脱しちゃったんですか？ うーん
まあ千人もほとんど九十パーセントぐらいね
できなかった人々もいます
まあ遊んだり寝てばっかりとかね
という人もいましたからね
実際にいたんです お釈迦様説法すると寝てばっかりして
それでどうでしょうかと
みんな聞いたところでお釈迦様はその人にはまあしょうがないと
それは病気だと また 悪いことをした人々も
あまりもおかしいことをしたんだから
それでも悟らなかった人もいましたしね
大体五十パーセントは悟りました
西洋では宗教から音楽が発展してって
仏教ではあんまりそういうのはないというか
さっきお話してくださったように
芸術に対する見方が違うんです
違うんです 芸術っていうのは欲の刺激世界でしょうに
体をいかに刺激するかっていう
なんで科学的に見ないんですかね
ブッダは別に科学的に見ているだけで
舞台を見るということは
目を刺激するだけでしょうに
音楽というのは耳を刺激するだけでしょうに
ただ肉体を刺激して 気分がいい
気分がいいと これ麻薬取ることと何が違うんですかね？それってどこが立派でしょうかね
だから芸術作品鑑賞することも
あのパクパクと 何でしたっけ
このおせんべいでもポテトチップスでも食べて楽しむことも
ただの体の楽しみですよ
どちらが優れてどちらが優れてないという話じゃないんですと
そういう科学性がない妄想のばっかしでもう引っかかってる人々は
もうこれは神のなんとかとかね
芸術は私は神のうんこですかと
芸術も音楽も みんなこの精神的なイカれた状態を作ってるだけ
だから体刺激するのはみんな我々日常でもいつでもやってるでしょうに
ご飯も食べているわ ご飯食べる時はそれにふりかけをかけたりするでしょうに
ふりかけなくても食えるのに
なんでふりかけかけるんですかね
刺激でしょ そのレベルです
ただ泣きたいと毎日泣きたいこといっぱいあるのに
なんで頭妄想の中で何かイメージでいろいろエピソード作って
それ読んで泣くんですかね
泣きたいこといっぱいあるのに
そうして進みながら泣いたりする人々は
実際人々苦しんでるでしょ
いっぱい出て行って人々のために何かやれば
芸術鑑賞する暇があったら
芸術を見て 人間の愛はよくわかりましたとか
芸術は人間の刺激だから世界からは消えませんし
芸術作品を作ることも
味噌汁を作って 何か焼き魚を作ってご飯を炊くことも同じ仕事なんです
価値は同じなんです  はい
それわからないと もうそれわかる人には何でも仕事はできます
それわかってないんだから仕事できないんです
神様からインスピレーションをくれるまで待ってるんです
作品を作るために 神様の御ならかもうなんとか
私はそれ態度で見てますけど
頭言葉 何でもそれも浮かぶんですよ
だからちゃんと具体的に物事を見ると
人間には才能っていうのはいくらでもある
この具体性がなくて 妄想の世界にいるんだから
才能がほとんどもう消えちゃって
だから大したことっていうのは
もう才能が全く機能しないない状態で
人間ここまで踏ん張ってるんだからね
だから大したもんですけど
よっぽど苦しいだろうと私は思います
そこまで苦しんで 楽しく楽しくなったってもね
どうで馬鹿じゃないかなという感じ方もあります
ちょっと心を穏やかにしてみれば
耳と音の刺激の関連関係だけわかれば
音なんかいくらでも湧いてきます
それはもうあの紙に書けば音楽ですからね
紙からインスピレーションが来るまで待っていると
まあ雑音ばっかしで音楽にはならない
他のも何でもいいんです
目で見る芸術にしたっても
生々しい人間が見て刺激を受けるでしょうね
だからそれに神のインスピレーションじゃなくて
自分の目の前にいる人々が喜ぶかないか
それでわかりますよ 例えば
この間この川本さんたちと一緒にインド行った時も
あちこちで川本さんスケッチ描いてると
インドのちっちゃな子供たちカチンカチンとそばに来てくぎ付けでついて待ってるんですね
驚いちゃって 私はそこら辺が私にとっては芸術なんです
一人が一生懸命何かスケッチを描いていて
そちらにもわけも言葉も何も通じないなんですけど
子供男一人がジーっとくぎ付けちゃって見ている
だからその子供はそれを楽しんでいたんですよ
それだけのことで そのがおじいさんすごいと言えるものを書いちゃったら
それ作品ですよ 終わりです
うん  はい あの昔からの人間の悩みっていうのは同じもので変わらないっていうことですと
物質的には進歩はあるかもしれないんですけど
人類に精神的な進歩っていうのはない
ないのですか？まあ...それも具体的に世の中を見てみれば
別に私は答える必要はないでしょうね
なさそうに思いますけど
少し悲しいかなと  それは個人の自由で悲しくなる方が
世間の実情には関係ない
だから苦しみも変わってないんだから
精神的な進歩っていうのは同じもんです
ずっとね だからちゃんと育てないと進めるわけじゃないんです
進むわけはないんですね
興味は違う 変わるんですよ
例えば物質的なことに興味が減ると
精神的なことに興味が上がる
精神的なことにすごく興味があると
物質的な豊かさっていうのは後回しにしちゃう
もう仕事をして食うものをやら
建物を造ることに必死になっちゃうと
精神っていうのはもうあるとも知らないことになっちゃうんです
現代社会は物質こそ全てだと思ってるんだから
もう精神っていうのはもうどん底にもう興味は減っている
進歩という意味じゃないんです
興味はありませんと 興味あるのは金だけですと
もうちょっと前だったら
例えばお釈迦様時代だったら
もう食うことだけは人生っていう方は思っていなかった人々もいましたし
その人たちは心の方がもっと大事やと
だから興味がある だから心に興味があるか
体に興味があるかっていうこと
それはもういろいろ変わります
それも興味があるなしだけであって
進歩っていうわけじゃないんです
どちら発展したっても
世界はもう大変ひどい目に遭います
例えば 精神的なことに興味があったとしましょう
宗教ブーム状態だと そうすると
あの人も宗教を作るは
この人も宗教を作るは
もう好き勝手に作りたい放題
宗教機構を作って宗教を作ったりして
お互いに話し合ったり
信者さん獲得に行って
それから自分の宗教を広げなくちゃいけないと言って
また結局は戦争に行くんです
超能力なければもう写真ごまかしでもサリンばらまいてでも
自分がもう超能力者と言いたくなります
だから精神的な方に興味があったんだからといってありがたいわけじゃないんです
結局は人間だらしないんだから
互いに殺し合い結果になって殺し合ったら
ああやばいなと思ったらストップする
物質豊かさも同じことで
金さえあれば全てをいいいらんという状態で
今現代社会は物質ばっかり発展させていくでしょ
これで自己破壊になっちゃう
それで戦争しているでしょうに
戦争したり 人を殺したり
あらゆる悪いことをやったりしているんです
だから物質に興味あったんだからって
世界が豊かになって幸せになるわけじゃないんです
結局は互いに殺し合いして破壊して
もうひどい目に遭う状態になっていくんです
だから その一歩手前で人間はだいたい気づいちゃって
まあちょっとやめましょうっていうことはやめるんです
そこが終わったところで
世界も終わり 一歩手前で気づく
気づいてきたんです 今までは
でも解決方法は見つけてない
気づくっていうのは飽きたってことですか
いや やばいと 例えば宗教ブームになっちゃって
みんなもうあれは超能力
この人は超能力とか あれこれはってお互いにサリンまで作って人殺しやっちゃうと
これはやばい やめましょうってなるんです
例えば 誰かの精神的なおかしい人が韓国で日本人はどんどんどんどん信者さんを獲得して
合同結婚式やら何やらやっていたでしょうに
あれ？これってやばいとわかったところで
それでやっとその宗教に対する興味が消えたでしょ
統一教会という宗教組織
もうなんとかちょっと一歩手前で気づいちゃうんです
それ気づかなかったら
大変などうなるかわからないんです
でも 麻原さんに気づく場合は
人を殺すまで待っていたんです
人を殺す前に もうただ知識人らしく
お互いに話をやったり
討論したりしたら そこでストップできたのに
麻原さんも大事に至らないで
あの頭の悪い若者たちもね
そんなに不幸に遭わないで済むはずでしたけどね
でも 一歩手前ではなくて
もうもう滑ってから気づいちゃったんですね
で 科学発展も何でも同じことですよ
え？原子爆弾も作って
もう地球を破壊するものは全部作って
あっ やっぱりやばいとわかってるんだから
もう使わないようにしてるだけでしょうに
だから飽きるっていう意味じゃないんです
やばいと こんな調子だったら
危険性です 危険に危険を感じる
察知する 人間 危険を察知するともう何とか
しようとする そこで歴史の流れ
文明の流れがそうやって回転していくんです
しかし 文明っていうのはある日突然消える
それはもう一歩手前で気づくことができなかった時なんです
そうすると文明もまるごと消えてしまう
これが仏教から見れば定石です
動物の法ってわかるんですか？ ん？ 動物も法ってわかるんですか？ 法は？動物はわからない
しかし 動物は気持ちはわかるんです
気持ちはみんな同じなんですよ
楽しいとかね いやいやとかね
そういう気持ちは動物も人間もみんな同じなんです
だから動物と会話したければ
気持ちで会話するんです
法はなんかわからない
でもそんなこと言ったとしても
動物に聞いたことはないんですけど
私はあの 私は知ってるところだ
なかなか動物も道徳やらね
まあわかるんですよ 付き合ってあるある時期
一緒に生活すると動物の方が寿命は早いし
だから私は見たとき 子供たちと一緒にいるでしょうし
向こうでスリランカででも
でもあの連中 何年経ってもバカのまんまで
もう犬とか猫とか飼っちゃうと
一年でも大人でしょ 全部自分の気持ちもわかるし
やってはいけないこともやってもいいことも全部わかってるし
見事に大人にすごいんです